I'm not a mom I am not a mom I am not a
mom I am not a mom not a mom I'm not a
mom I'm not a mom
what do you guys do for work I have two
jobs so I'm working anywhere from On The
Low End 60 to 80 hours a week I'm a
businessman wait what do you say you do
I'm a business manager and then also a
head chef that's cool you're in your
garage I like that what do you do for a
living I'm a video editor oh
I work at CBS right now I am an interior
designer I've been doing it about three
years I'm still in school but I'm
working for a firm in Costa Mesa I work
for a non-profit in stem so Science Tech
when I do science videos on the side the
Asian Bill Nye kind of cool
so I was a nursing major for a while but
realized I hated it so left school try
to figure out what I really wanted to do
so for the meantime I am a bartender and
server
Sharon she said she was a bartender
part-time I figured that would be a
typical side gig part-time mom part-time
bartender I work at Starbucks come on
part-time but then I'm a full-time
student as well so what are you studying
I'm studying Health Science it's um
Healthy Lifestyles coach and fitness
science what's your favorite kids show
Arthur's gray I was a Teletubbies girl
oh you're making a comeback oh yeah the
new purple wiggle oh
it's the purple one yeah that's why like
she's cool but then there's another one
where it's the guy and then they're
remaking Blue's Clues
um
it's but it's like the updated Steve
it's so cool yeah so I was a little
suspicious of Jade and uh Susan because
they were saying shows that are recent
and like the changes of the shows that
were happening so it was kind of just
like you guys are watching kid shows you
might have kids do you guys have kids
I was gonna try this oh my gosh you guys
have dogs okay yeah I do
too
I have two snakes as well yes I want a
dog when my apartment won't let me have
it how does anyone feel about kids in
general they're so cool after school for
sure I like to give them back for their
moms
yeah but like fruit monsters
if you like this episode and you want to
see more make sure to like this video
And subscribe to our Channel now let's
figure out who the mole is
[Music]
foreign
was wearing seemed kind of mummish
she radiated badass mom energy I was
just like damn
[Music]
I think they were suspecting me based
off of the comment I made about the kids
shows with Blue's Clues and The Wiggles
I was like oh dang it I just saw that on
Tick Tock type of thing that was intense
guys like show me how to change a diaper
I had a wipe experience oh okay that you
hold it it's the assertiveness of Jade I
was like oh the fact that she came up
with that so quickly maybe she's a mom
herself
um like let's imagine the baby's like on
the floor
not the floor
there's no you lift up the legs and wipe
I think I was making myself worse at it
because I was like I'm not going to show
you guys that I know how to change a
diaper and make it seem as though I'm a
mom even though it's not just a act that
is Centered for moms like family members
know how to do that I thought that was
going to be a great idea and it turns
out I got nothing from that question no
knowledge at all except for that it was
a bad question do you guys want kids I
don't think so right now I just feel
like there's so much life that I still
want to like live and I'm definitely
okay with waiting I'm 26 I do not want
kids right now my mom actually had me
and my sisters young I was able to just
see that second hand on the struggle I
want to travel more I'm married me and
my husband thanks thank you since my mom
had my brother and I pretty late and I
think once she really figured out her
life and did everything she wanted to do
was the perfect time and she didn't want
to have kids until my grandma because
she's from Malaysia my mom told her I'm
not having these kids unless you come to
America and help me take care of them so
she wanted to make sure she had all the
support she just was not being direct
about if she did want kids or she didn't
want kids at all she was just talking
about her mom's experience so I was just
like I think it might be you so you kind
of just talked about your mom's um
perspective so is our children like in
your future is it something that you
would like to have one day or I
literally just had this conversation
with somebody else and it's very I'm not
a hard yes or a hard no I think it just
really depends on where I am in my life
and it also depends on the person I'm
having kids with yeah so what do you
guys think of the term MILF like what do
you what do you Vision with you honestly
that word isn't it like the most popular
category I'm like it's like
an independent woman who's just like I
got kids and yeah there's an association
I think with the term MILF like you said
typically they're pretty independent are
they single moms are they single mom and
that's why they're being associated with
MILF all mothers are beautiful but I
think like the like biblical MILF is
probably the mom who still has her
identity that's a great way to put it
they still watch like weird owl videos
on their free time are they still like
do whatever weird stuff they did before
having the kid what do you guys do in
your free time I go to the gym I could
tell and I study thank you
go to the gym I have fur babies of my
own and I love to spend time with them
honestly just anything just going out
events I'm kind of the opposite I'm
chronically online I don't get out much
when I do it's usually for like a cool
like metal concert trying to get back
into entertainment again I do some music
on the side and you said again what
stopped you from entertainment oh well
just you know just work I mean I want to
do more than just CBS long term so I'm
trying to get into real estate too I'm
just gonna study that next month and um
yeah just different things that's just
kind of what I'm doing for income
currently but yeah
just uh Kristen she was stumbling on her
words and moving around a lot after I
had asked her about the entertainment
industry I really enjoy work I know
that's like kind of taboo but I like to
make money it gives me a lifestyle that
is comfortable same my my work breathes
into my life and I love my job because
it's freelance I get to work whenever I
want wherever I want so
I started to get scared because I was
like it's either Jade or I can't trust
anyone in here
counted the votes and we have a
three-way tie Christian
Jade
and Sharon
each one of you will have 30 seconds to
State your case here's the thing I can
barely take care of myself
I mean
to admit this most days I don't wake up
before like 11 A.M to have such a
screwed weird sleep schedule because I
stay up all night and I don't see Sun as
much as I should and also I'm kind of
terrified of passing a human through my
body there's that
um I don't really think I'm financially
stable to have a baby right now and
that's yeah that's pretty much I'm still
saving it for a dog like that's what my
goal is right now and uh definitely
don't want a child anytime soon so I
mean same case I'm not in the best
financial situation just a couple months
ago I really accepted the fact that I
was just going to be homeless until I
truly believe in miracles I ended up
living with the roomie but
I mean exactly what she said the thought
of passing a baby through me I'm just
because you hear all the horror stories
of birthing someone I'm just like do I
really want to go through that but again
going back to the hard yes or hard no
they're just so many factors that are
dependent
foreign
I kind of was just letting everyone
speak before I think that's why I got
voted out it's probably just because I
was quieter
do you think the mole is still in the
box and you'd like to continue playing
the game please raise your hand
okay for every person you vote out that
is not the mole the money will be
reduced in half
but let's be direct we think it's either
you or you and the reason I think it's
you is because I actually think it's you
but I but they think it might be I think
it's you yeah because you weren't sure
about the baby question you're like
talked about your mom a little bit and
why I think it's you a sleep schedule
like if you have a baby you're probably
up at weird hours of the night you know
what I mean even though I am too my
auntie de presents make me sleep like 12
hours a day so that's a big part of it
fair yeah do you guys have any
meaningful tattoos that you guys are
comfortable showing right now this is my
dad he died last year this is a
signature it's my only one though I just
got this tattoo on the back of my leg it
says all is well well is all so cool
I only have one it's a g it's my best
friend's first name Gabby best friend I
know really I know I love my best friend
I don't ever tattooed on me oh look I
love my best friend don't have her name
tattooed on me so I was like that's a
child that's you have a child's name to
do it on you so I was gonna say I have
my grandmother the day she was born to
the day she passed away with an infinity
sign in her name and then metallic is
one of my favorite bands no it's not it
is are you serious yeah what
I have a metallic inspired tattoo on my
inner arm that is such a cool surprise I
have this because I just saw it on the
internet I thought it was cute
um I got this with my best friend see
she has the best idea
but is it your best friend's initial no
it's mine oh that's cool what's your
relationship with your baby's father
what's it like you guys talk a lot or I
don't have one see I'm really bad at
this you said you're married but do you
guys live alone or do you live with
other people do you have a partner
um it's a complicated situation right
now aren't they all we're figuring it
out
I live by myself though okay
I'm living with family and I recently
broke up with my boyfriend he didn't
deserve you period I live with a
roommate
okay and my cat
um also a roommate but two dogs and then
her dog too I just live with my husband
and then our two dogs
all right
just because she was also giving a very
loving comforting energy where she's
like all right it's almost giving come
on kids let's get together and let's
talk about this some more
once the first round passed I only was
paying attention to her
I was shook I really didn't think I gave
any kind of mom energy you think the
mole is still in the box and you'd like
to continue playing the game please
raise your hand
the lights turn green that means you
have voted the mole out and you all went
the light turns red that means the mole
is still in the box and you lose
period
okay you're not a mom no neither are you
I'm sorry that's a very cute idea
on my count the mall will step forward
and reveal themselves three
two one
I actually have a 19 year old and a 14
year old I am a team I was a Teen Mom
you're an inspiration that's Super Rad
my daughter's ours I do get called a
MILF I take it as a compliment it
depends on who it comes from if it's
coming from another mom another female
then I'm like okay Real Recognize is
real but then if it comes from a male
I'm like okay somebody's been on the
little orange and black block site and
then I kind of try to stay away was it
the tattoo you were the only one it's
funny because I voted this way and then
you I feel so bad I just want to
apologize
but it's a compliment when you're sweet
and material
which you know I do take that as a
compliment because I feel like I have
zero maternal instincts and maybe I do
because like I have two fur babies so
I'm like my baby motherhood which is
within Womanhood comes in so many
different forms I just picture like a
hot mom driving her Range Rover with her
kids in the back it's just a boss lady I
think that at the end of the day taking
the word back like hell yeah I'm a MILF
and you know you don't have to worry
about what the weird kind of like pervy
people say it's like it's a word of
empowerment
it's like is this how is that how you do
it this oh I'm sorry is that how you do
it oh hope you brought an umbrella